great visual effects can accompany it
can completely change a film's
experience
when i was seven living in taylor
michigan my mother took me to watch
terminator 2 at the theaters
i'm pretty sure she didn't know what the
movie was about and
to her and my surprise we got to see
some stuff
we got to see t-1000 get his head blown
off and then form back together
and arnold cut his arm skin to reveal a
robot hand
and i just remember glancing at my mom a
few times trying to see if this was okay
for me to watch
and my mom playing it cool as if she
meant to bring me to this movie
but maybe that's just my memory maybe
she reveled in the fact that she got to
see a badass mom
duke it out with future robots with her
son in 1991
the way that the technology and the
expertise in visual effects has advanced
in the 30 years since t2
is staggering they have become the key
element in many of the biggest films in
cinema history
and with each year those who are the
best in the world
top even themselves and take the art to
another level
like this year's nominees love and
monsters
matt sloan genevieve camilleri matt
everett
and brian cox the midnight sky
the midnight sky matthew kasmir
christopher lawrence
max solomon and david watkins
mulan sean faden anders langlands
seth mowry and steve ingram
the one and only ivan nick davis greg
fischer
ben jones and santiago coloma martinez
andrew jackson david lee andrew lockley
and scott fisher
and the oscar goes to tennant
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh well all my colleagues are overseas
unfortunately
for them they have to let me speak so
this is what you get
it's amazing amazing our visual effects
team on
uh tenet we did so many things and
there's so many departments so we have
to thank
not just in our own but in uh
you know the art department and nathan
and camera department hoyta and of
course our
stunt coordinator george cottle is
amazing
and uh you know but it all goes back to
our director
christopher nolan he uh he leads us all
and gives us amazing opportunities to do
amazing things
and i'd like to thank my family my wife
my amazing crew
and uh and my father who
who won this same award thank you